it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday Follies and for that we turn to
Raymond Arroyo Fox News contributor all
right Raymond we reported this earlier
the president had another big bidenomic
speech yay yeah but Laura there were a
few moments that you won't see anywhere
else okay but at least the president is
on alert that he should avoid falling in
public I came to office I was determined
determined to end the trickle-down
economy excuse me this little stands out
well I'll make sure I don't trip over
maybe I stand I make myself three inches
taller take diverse Old Mill
Bucksport you can see exactly where to
go if you go to online to go to
invest.com invest.com
punch in wherever neighborhood you want
to find out about
or maybe not Laura when we went to
invest.com this came up
like bidenomics the page is not working
then the president forgot to sign the
executive order in manufacturing he had
to double back sort of like Kamala
Harris who may need to double back
herself this is her explanation for the
success of bidenomics most Americans are
a four hundred dollar unexpected expense
away from bankruptcy
maybe they should have asked kjp to
explain the basic surtax uh syntax is
difficult for her I totally understand
we're just going to uh not uh not
discuss any specifics any specifics
no pacifics maybe she can give get into
The Atlantics Laura uh look we have a
Fox News Alert sorry to break in tonight
the president finally recognizing his
four-year-old granddaughter Navy Hunter
Biden's love child in a statement to
people the President says this is not a
political issue it's a Family Matter
Jill and I only want what's best for all
our grandchildren including Navy
oh well that's nice A little late but
better late than never does that means
she gets a Christmas cookie or perhaps a
stocking at the White House next year
later this year well we'll we'll have to
check on that we'll see
all right I'm granting you three wishes
oh good okay where where I know we're
tight tonight so here we go my first if
you're going to rob a bank and who are
on Ohio I wish you wouldn't make the
recycling bin your accomplice
hand behind your back
foreign
Cruise was definitely not involved in
this Heist Laura why didn't he just
crawl into the police station overhang
could have been quicker
no it's very okay what's the second wish
okay my second wish people would spend
more time embracing who they are rather
than playing dress-up and demanding
affirmation this Japanese guy dresses as
a collie in a fifteen thousand dollar
dog outfit and yes he's taken for walks
[Music]
yeah
Collies
there's now a trend of adults dressing
as babies and they're part of something
called the adult baby diaper lover
Community how do you like to run that
Nursery in group
that's called getting old and having to
wear Depends okay so why are you just
wait until you get
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else